e.t is learning new details about chris
rock and will smith's altercation and
what's being called the slap heard
around the world following a crack from
the comedian about will's wife jada
pinkett smith oh richard
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith
so what does one do after getting
slapped during the academy awards well
if you're chris you don't let it ruin
your night a source tells e.t he went to
a high-profile bash thrown by talent
agent guy osiri
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television
despite his televised assault which was
broadcast in over 200 countries chris
appeared unfazed and was having a good
time at the party
the source says he didn't want to let
the incident with will ruin his night
out with friends chris was still in
shock by the whole incident and didn't
want it to become a whole thing at the
party so he didn't talk too much about
it
the source added honestly chris seemed
to really be having fun and not letting
it get to him
in wake of the shocking moment many
celebs voiced their support for chris
you know
i would like to more of a straight
apology
to chris i thought will's performance
was amazing and i'm sorry that he
tarnished it with this behavior
meanwhile seemingly just as many
reactions sided with the newly minted
oscar winner i seen a man
stand up for his wife
which we don't see that much anymore
they put her face up on the screen
looked over at his wife she was hurt
while chris partied elsewhere the smith
family let loose at the star-studded
vanity fair party
trophy in hand that's will wrapping
summertime for the gathered crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
and an eyewitness at the party tells e.t
will was acting as though nothing
happened earlier the source adds
everyone was pretty much ignoring the
entire situation including will
i think that the
[Music]
i think that the two gentlemen need to
deal with it and i think that the
academy needs to deal with it but he
probably won't be able to keep the
blinders up for much longer i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to all my fellow
nominees the academy announced an
investigation is underway saying in a
statement on monday we've officially
started a formal review around the
incident and will explore further action
and consequences while many in hollywood
were critical of his actions will has
plenty of people in his corner
the fact that i am an extension of this
legacy is such an amazing honor
including jabari banks who took up the
fresh prince mantle in bel air the
reimagined series produced by its og
star you know you have to protect your
family and uh you know i believe in him
and what he stands for and so you know
he's a stand-up guy and i'll stick by
[Music]